have you done research are you getting
ready to vote yeah I have and this is
super exciting for me because it's my
first time to vote and I think that it's
really cool this year because a lot of
young people are really getting involved
and I see it all over media my dad has
been on the Trump trains it's day one
and very outspoken about that and at
first I wasn't sure I was like I don't
know like I'll go I really wanted to
look into it myself
and I did and uh I guess I'm on the
Trump during to now and make America
great again I just feel like I don't
know I just feel like I'm aligned most
with his beliefs and everything in views
and Trust to them and so that's who I'm
going with now I guess for down to the
two so it's kind of time to make a
stance would you join your dad out on
the trail anything like that oh yeah
definitely and I probably will get hate
for this there's a lot people get really
into policies which you should you
should look on to it you should care
about it but it's a touchy subject yeah
you know what there are a lot of
opinions on both sides and I think as
long as you've done your research and
you feel strongly about what you believe
then that is that's the whole point
mm-hmm so feathers be nice good on you
no hater diet right